hier après midi sur la commune de
til-châtel en côte d'or
une voiture et un poids lourd entre en
collision avec le choc la voiture prend
feu
ses occupants deux enseignants d'une
trentaine d'années sont découverts sans
vie par les pompiers
plus tôt dans la journée le conducteur
d'une camionnette a perdu la vie sur
l'a6 dans l'yonne
trois autres personnes sont blessées il
s'agit en fait de deux accidents
successifs
un poids lourd s'est d'abord couché sur
les voies dans le bouchon qui s'est
formé derrière un autre accident a
impliqué plusieurs véhicules enfin cette
nuit sur l'a36 le conducteur d'une
voiture s'est encastrée à l'arrière d'un
poids lourd
il n'a pas survécu à ses blessures
[Applaudissements]